[Music]
hello everybody what's up how's it going
so today we're about to review a movie
which many of you all heard about So
today we're diving into the Multiverse
with a revie view of the highly
anticipated movie Spider-man across the
spider verse so this animated
Masterpiece is a followup of the
groundbreaking Spider-Man into the
spider
verse so grab your web shooters and
let's swing into
action so now let's start with a quick
summary of the Spiderman across the
spiderverse this film continues the
story of Miles Morales the teenage
Spider-Man as he explores the Multiverse
encountering a diverse array of spider
people it's an action-packed adventure
that promises to take us on Epic Journey
Through the
spiderverse one of the most stacking
aspects of this movie it is character
development so we get to see Miles
Morales grow up as Spider-Man and
character Dynamics are simply
fantastic whether is the return of Peter
Parker or the introduction of new
characters I don't know but each one
adds depth to the
narrative the relationships between
these characters are truly the heart of
the
film well now let's talk about the
animation Spider-Man across the
spiderverse once again pushes the
boundaries of the animation the visual
style is innovative combining various
animation techniques from hand drone to
CGI giving the movie a unique and
vibrant look the action sequences are
mindblowing and the attention to detail
is
[Music]
remarkable so the plot of the film is
captivating it seamlessly waves
through multi Le story lines and the
concept of the Multiverse is executed
brilliantly the film explores themes of
identity family
responsibility which are at the core of
the Spider-Man
character the pacing keeps you engaged
from start to finish and there are
plenty surprises along the
way so let's talk about the voice cast
The Voice cast in Spider-Man across the
spider
is topnotch topnotch
quality the returning of the new actors
and develop and deliver outstanding
performance they do deliver outstanding
performance bringing they they basically
bring characters to life like that's all
they
do like you'll feel a genuine connection
to these animated heroes and villains
like it's genuine
feeling the audio and music are also
worth mentioning the audio and music are
perfectly perfectly matched with the
film they enhance the emotional depth of
the story and the sound design immerses
you into the world of Spider-Man and the
soundtrack is filled with catchy tunes
that will stick with you long after the
movie
ends well so in conclusion Spiderman
across the spiderverse is a Triumph in
animation and
storytelling it builds builds upon
succeeds success of its predecessor and
takes
Spider-Man to new heights it's a film
not only that entertains but also
resonates on a deeper level if you're a
Spider-Man fan or just a lover of great
cinema this is a must watch trust me in
this so I highly recommend Spider-Man
across the verse to all viewers of all
ages and it's a spectacular cinematic
experience that will leave you swinging
with joy don't miss out on web
slinging Adventure so like this movie is
you might say it's childish cuz it's
animated but not trust me anyone can
watch it and like they will experience
pure fun and entertainment with
it so thank you for joining us today and
as always don't forget to subscribe to
my teachers
YouTube well that's it for today peace
[Music]
out
he